foreign
hey folks Mark Norman here with joke
world try not to laugh
can I just visit people in prison
do I have to know them do you have to
have their name and their number I think
you go Tyrone you're all right yeah
they're on your side what did you call
when you would knock on the door and run
away oh we called it a ding dong and run
or something like that there was ding
dong ditch ding dong ditch yeah that's
it there was a really bad one the worst
Asian porn star by the way I don't know
if you know her
vending machines kill more people in
America than sharks how about that fun
fact because they shake and they fall on
you
but that's really hard I mean you got a
really pull you know people shake them
though and they they really yeah it's
like they shake and fall like Biden
well sharks don't kill uh many people I
don't think no no I think they bite and
they spit because they like it's like me
when I lick I'm like oh they wanna they
were hoping for something else right and
you smell the blood
oh a Chum that's what I'm gonna start
calling period blood Chum
but yeah they don't do it so I think
they don't kill people often right not
at all
two a year tops all right well that's
different than not at all oh sweet
Caroline take a walk thank you oh wait
oh wait you know what one I really hate
Don't Stop Believing oh oh yeah but
let's be honest when you're in a car
alone you're gonna belt it it's just
melting that and you're not shit-faced
there's something no no no this is the
only drive when I'm shifting
I didn't know how to do anything yeah
you know I mean I just had the thing of
like I'm gonna go for it yeah Vibe like
I'm gung-ho which is I think at the end
that's always worked for me gung-ho is
your uncle but uh
I did crack once yeah did you really
yeah a fan gave me Molly
and I was like oh and I mean the lady
went to Paris we went to the Louvre and
I said let's do the Molly and we took
crack
we're in the Molly like you took cracks
shaking and drooling
you're the only person
you're the only person ever to do crack
at the Loop in the loop I thought you
had to smoke it well I ate it I ate the
rock now they you're doing crack at the
Louvre is whatever you gotta be proud
about this what was it like yeah no
one's done sucked really because I ate
it which I don't think you're supposed
to do so my body didn't know what was
going on and I ran right to the bathroom
I'm [__] insane like Dumb and Dumber
[__] at the loose so all these
French people are like
you know it was bad but I saw some
beautiful art I'm sweating with my lady
we're sweating and twitching stare at
the Mona Lisa I love the idea of Norman
seeing Arts students
[Laughter]
[Music]
oh my God
she got framed and nobody got it she got
framed I made a reference because this
afrobeats music is Big right now yeah so
I say is I was listening to I think so
several beats I don't know but you guys
were there together weren't you no no no
I got to do it because he wasn't there
afrobeats that's what the cops do
and there's a Downy Barbie really yeah I
wanted his merch is I want to order a
bunch and have it as merch it's a guy it
is I got it the doll yeah look I never
saw it they did a good job really yeah
because I was Googling it like yo what
and it they did good I mean that guy in
the lab must have been you gotta really
walk a fine line with a downsy doll
because it's got to look downsy but not
insulting yeah but he's got to research
them all the time I have a joke about it
where they're like closer yeah
I know they're just looking at photos of
the Special Olympics every year yeah
yeah
absolutely Google the down the model
like one
[Laughter]
oh I'm going to stealth mode after that
one
[Music]
uh
that's funny that's funny that deserves
a smoke what are you looking up shut up
there you go
just shut up for four seconds you
running motor oh they could have gone
harder I know yeah this is this is just
an ugly gal that's just an ugly Barbie
yeah four seconds is up what were they
gonna do yeah wow that wasn't nice for
seconds though I really felt every
moment of that should have more muscles
too they're very strong they are very
strong they need bigger lats yeah I want
her lifting a car or eating she looks
normal or petting a cat too hard
foreign
at the Hollywood comedy store and I
check ideas and one weekend he did a
weekend there wow and he came in and I
was sitting there I was so scared
because I'm you know I'll blow him yeah
I mean like a little snake bite on his
dick and he's like I need you know I
mean that's an emergency that's yeah but
I wouldn't so like this kind I don't get
[__] I died I like you but I'm just
saying I'm gonna suck your dick but my
point is yeah
that's crazy in the Korean no way no my
point is is that so Carling walks by me
and he goes what's your name Kid ah
Bobby Lee and he goes comic I go yeah
and he goes cool and he did a set a year
later I'm still working the back door
and he does the weekend again
he doesn't say hi to me but no he does
that he walks up and he goes Mr Lee and
he walked right past me I mean in his
defense pretty good odds
you know he was kind of talking about
all the trans stuff or whatever and it
was like no one really cared yeah which
to me it was like an interesting like
okay the people giving a [__] trying to
get mad about that stuff to me is like
somewhat over other than like a tiny
corner of the internet I hope you're
right I know that's why I kind of want
to see what you thought of that well my
thing is like I hate I hate this
argument like Leah Thomas the swimmer
person you know yeah and everybody's
like oh when do you care about women
swimming and I'm like
when this unprecedented thing that never
happened before happens
yeah you know it's like oh oh 9 11 when
did you care about skyscrapers
I hate that argument what do you care
about a a bicycling I'm like well Lance
Armstrong's on drugs and he started
[__] Sheryl Crow and [__] on her
tits and gave her breast cancer that's
what I started caring about cycling that
is a good boy I don't even care about it
I just care about this exact news story
and this exact swimmer when did you
start caring about that also on top of
that when did you start caring about the
one news story that everyone tells you
you're not allowed to talk about
anything yeah I'm nibble in the grocery
store oh yeah that's what the whole
produce is for yeah he's a known Thief
not to mention the hot bar that hot bar
doesn't stand a chance with these Sticky
Fingers
you can just put like chicken and pasta
in the bowl you just eating and eating
and shopping yeah no you're not you're
not wrong that's what Whole Foods is I
go in there I eat a cup of soup I leave
[Applause]
I thought everybody did that uh you and
other homeless people I'm sure yeah all
right well they keep the eye on the
hobos and I'm sitting pretty just wear a
nice shirt nobody says I got a mouthful
of chicken noodle
that's why I'm so jealous not to change
something I'm jealous of guys who are in
a feet yeah because they're everywhere
like we like tits but you don't really
get to see tits out in the wild but
flip-flops open toe sandal Barefoot
women they're just there that's true I
never thought about that must be nice
yeah it must be nice to live just in a
smorgasbord like every everywhere is a
nudist colony yeah exactly I mean and
you could be one of those guys like hey
you're coming in here you got to take
your shoes off come to my house I can't
do that with a bra yeah
yeah they saying Italian women are the
most beautiful women by country I mean
yes that's probably mine I like a middle
Easter not Middle Eastern uh
Mediterranean to me is the hottest what
Ukraine in there you got yeah
British women she doesn't show the teeth
if you notice that go back up smart move
there limey
what do we got next Spanish women from
Spain oh she's like a thicker Penelope
Cruz I think that actually is Penelope
Cruz sorry never mind Penelope Cruz got
fat oh [__] no she looks beautiful like
that you look great Pinel I like a
thickie yeah yeah I mean I can cruise by
a Taco Bell even when someone kills
someone or something like now you can
watch the security footage of like the
whole murder like yeah you know like the
documentary is just like him going into
the apartment him coming out him going
to the store to buy the cleaning
products it's like everything is filled
well that George Floyd thing was like
awkwardly long how they just watched it
for that long and I was like fast
forward and it was just still yeah
okay
look at the DVDs like skip scene
I wanted the commentary
sorry but yeah no it was so long it was
crazy it was long yeah you think like
the Irishman it needed yeah except the
violence was way more realistic yeah I
wonder if the guy who filmed his
approoter footage they were like come on
[__] always filming enjoy the moment
back then it was weird yeah and now it's
like it's like do we've not filmed
anything four guys were on a podcast
right now let me just say this oh yeah
uh oh did you just [__] yourself
dude that's a [__] your pants that's
what you call an uncooperative fart life
is like LeBron he's slowing down
yeah it was like years of farting
perfectly and then you know he hits a
certain age oh dude I felt your pain
with that that was rough that was like
the George Floyd video for so long but
it did happen and we just kept watching
it over it's like yeah it was one of
those except now we can't breathe
I have to play well on the internet four
white guys talking about that uh yeah
that's what thrives on you
have you seen Tim Dillon
he's doing very well do you ever take
nights off specifically rarely maybe a
Sunday here and there yeah on those
nights do you feel a sense like you're
at peace and you're restful or do you
have guilt about not being on stage I
have guilt and the wife is like you have
a night off let's fill it with [__] no
one wants to do this stuff which I
understand because I'm never there so I
get it so I try to just suck it up and
do her [__] you should hear you're
such a [__] [__] her [__] it's
probably like dinner at like Cipriani
that's true that's such [__] she's
the normal she's the same one here
I'm aware of that oh man I had to eat
pumpkin caviar it's such [__] yeah
you know because she'll she'll be like
oh you're special coming out we should
do a thing and I'm like no no thanks you
want to do a thing you want to have
somebody that is it is and I appreciate
it that wants to celebrate you like that
that's true it's also like I feel like
your agents and your people should do
that [__] too yeah I guess I try not to
mix emotion with them right right keep
it real robotic crack the whip yeah you
work for me sign the [__] thing yeah
so make them throw a [__] party for
you with an open bar and you can invite
whoever and it's summertime in New York
and you can do it on a rooftop yeah
that's not so bad ideally I'd like to
have someone throw me a party but not go
so the party is just happening but I'm
not there I'm watching TV there's a
hologram of you
can take a picture with them yeah it's
glitching out quickly
I'm gay
great film is great in there
[Music]
that's right he got popped with Kitty
porn who the principal of the redheaded
principal you know Apple's searching our
phones for yes
back in a stealth mode Apple's searching
are like Greg's not fair
at joke world
and the world is wrld
that's a great uh YouTube channel joke
World check it out